let's just start with liverpool just
down the road from where you are this
morning um any idea uh about what has
happened and particularly the hero
cabbie that we're all talking about this
morning
i think so and you know add to what you
just said kay that you know huge amount
of thanks to the cab driver who appears
to have acted very quickly it's
obviously too early to speculate but to
launch what looks like it may have been
a terrorist attack to do that on
remembrance sunday to do that in a great
city like liverpool it's just it's an
appalling
thing that may just have unfolded for us
and
you know just pay tribute to the bravery
and the spirit of the people of
liverpool who who've stood up over and
over again against adversity and
thoughts with all of them this morning
indeed so um i wonder if i could ask you
uh where we are with uh kovid this
morning as far as the labour party is
concerned we're seeing what's happening
in europe austria
germany
netherlands they've all got varying
levels of restrictions in place do we
need to take guidance from them
i think we need to take guidance from
our own experts who've been saying for
some time that we need to do a number of
things we need to introduce proper sick
pay for people who have to self-isolate
we need to ventilate our buildings
properly particularly our schools we've
got some of the worst ventilated
buildings in europe and as it gets
harder to keep doors and windows open
we're seeing much more pressure on
schools and rising covered rates
as well and we need to put a rocket
under the booster programme we should be
hitting about 500 000 boosters a day
we're only hitting about half of that at
the moment we should be bringing medics
out of retirement having many more
pop-up clinics so that people can access
the booster much more quickly and
utilizing community pharmacies as well
there's a lot the government could do
but there's just a feeling that yet
again they've taken their eye off the
ball with the crisis that they've been
engulfed in over recent weeks and just
not used the time that they've had in
order to stand us in the best possible
stead as we approach christmas
in all fairness um you know we were at
almost half a million booster jobs
yesterday 446 000. so it's certainly
heading in the right direction one
wonders though um when that should be
opened up to other age groups i think
it's just the over 55s at the moment
yeah i mean obviously the government is
relying on the categories that the
experts have put forward
so that we move through those categories
as quickly as possible and the key is
not start moocking around with the
categories but just to get
some speed into this process you're
right that yesterday was a particularly
good day i hope that that trend
continues but there's also the issue of
young people as well and trying to make
sure that young people get access to the
vaccine too i'm particularly worried
about that we're particularly worried
about that because a lot of young people
have missed a huge amount of school
and more in some parts of the country
than in others
and
that is going to have devastating
implications for them if they can't
catch up and if we've got young people
out of school again for extended periods
over
over the winter there's going to be
implications of that for decades and
decades to come so we need the
government to really get a grip on this
really put a rocket under it and we
we've been saying for a long time that
we thought that math squaring and social
distancing should be part of plan a i
think the government ought to be
thinking very seriously about
setting the right example and setting
the rights home starting with the house
of commons where it's still appalling
the way that many tory mps are not
wearing masks and social distancing at
the moment
let's turn to something very much on
brief for you uh what's happening on the
poland belarus border uh what on earth
is going on there and what should we be
doing about it
well
actually uh this is one of those rare
occasions where i think the government
is broadly
right that
the actions that lukashenko
is taking
is appalling he's using vulnerable
refugees as pawns in a game we recently
imposed sanctions on belarus
if
lukashenko isn't careful i think he may
well see a united front from europe
britain and the united states to impose
further sanctions and i certainly don't
think we should rule that out we've sent
some troops across to try and support
the polish government but the one great
gap here is support for those refugees
who are being used as a pawn in this
political
game we've got to get more humanitarian
support in to help them the unhcr is
currently on the ground but their
efforts are very limited it's emergency
and crisis care at the moment we've got
reports of refugees including children
freezing to death
at the moment we've got to make sure
that we work with the international
community to get help into them we can't
allow them to pay the price for what is
a power play and a power game between
authoritarian leaders and the european
union
hearing from the head of the armed
forces speaking to trevor phillips
actually just yesterday's generals nick
carter of course warning that belarus
conflict could escalate to war and
become
weaponized um how concerned should we be
about that and indeed our role in that
well i think we should be very concerned
about what's happening in belarus and
also what is happening in ukraine and i
think we ought to be absolutely crystal
clear to president putin that the
international community speaks with one
voice we will not tolerate states
territorial integrity
their sovereignty being threatened or
undermined we're leading members of nato
and we stand together with our nato
allies or allies when they're under
threat but it's in nobody's interest to
see this escalate so while i think sir
general nick cutter is absolutely right
to say that we should be concerned about
this the key for politicians is about
how you de-escalate those tensions and
that means being firm and consistent in
our approach to the russian government
and the belarus authorities but also
being prepared to have a dialogue being
prepared to work with our international
partners in order to make sure that this
situation doesn't escalate and that we
don't see further tensions in the next
24 hours
yeah i mean you're talking about russian
soldiers a hundred thousand russian
soldiers we believe uh near ukraine's
border as we speak what does being firm
with russian with russia look like
well we've we've been very clear as a
country that we there will be
sanctions and financial penalties for
russia for officials around president
putin
and for the belarusian government as
well
in fact sanctions were imposed on
lukashenko just a few months ago with
full support of all political parties in
the house of commons but there's more
that we could be do to be tough on
russia we've had
a russia report a report that shows how
london is still a haven for the dark
money that helps to sustain the putin
regime the prime minister's been sitting
on that for 18 months a whole series of
recommendations in there not a single
one of them implemented in full for as
long as this government isn't prepared
to take tough action to make sure that
the uk isn't a home for some of that
dark money the uh the message that will
be received loud and clear in moscow is
that the government will say one thing
but do quite another we need to see some
really tough and robust action from the
government on that to show the uk
leading by example and we need to look
to nato to see what they can and will do
although others might say given what
happened uh in afghanistan and the
withdrawal there they're about as much
use as a chocolate fire guard at the
moment
well nato isn't just some amorphous
entity we are nato we're part of nato
we're leading members of nato and
contributors and i think it's absolutely
right that we reaffirm our commitment to
stand with our allies when they're under
threat and under attack but i do think
that the foreign secretary is correct in
saying that although she wants to see a
robust response from president putin she
wants to see him intervene in order to
prevent this sort of disgraceful
behavior that we're seeing from
lukashenko at the current time
it's not in anybody's interest to try to
escalate those tensions to try to rush
headlong into some kind of standoff
between troops on both sides of the
border we need to get humanitarian
assistance to those who are in urgent
and dire need and it's right that we've
sent some of our own troops over to
support the polish authorities as they
grapple with this problem in real time
on the ground
um sleaze being talked about in the
house of commons uh today labor not
without guilt when it comes to that it's
fair to say kyostama stood on a
manifesto in 2015 which promised to ban
mps from paid consultancies he then took
nine and a half grand um from the
government of gibraltar just a few
months later you all need to look at
yourselves
look i think i do look at myself all the
time i mean you know it's a sort of job
where i don't think i've ever felt as
accountable in any other walk of life
and
i grapple with how i spend my time as an
mp um and i try to make sure that
everything is sort of fun and
transparent as possible and for me
that's the key
in the end there are some of my
constituents for example who won't
really appreciate the fact that i've
taken on this additional role the shadow
foreign secretary and the others others
that are very proud of that and think
that it
it helps to to ensure that i do a better
job for them as the mp for wigan the key
surely is that we are upfront and
transparent about what we do
particularly when there's finances
concerned and there's money changing
hands so that the public can make their
own minds up about whether we're doing
the right thing and there's no
suggestion at all that kierstama didn't
follow the rules he did follow the rules
and he declared
that money and that is the difference
i'm afraid between him and owen
patterson who broke the rules and didn't
declare many of those transactions and
the prime minister as well we've just
had revelations over the weekend about
further revelations about the jennifer
curie affair i don't care what the prime
minister does in his personal life or
with his free time but i do care when
those transactions those relationships
that may have a huge bearing on how
public money is spent aren't up for open
and transparent so the public can make
up their minds that's when the rock
starts to set in and that's what we've
got to change
just before we let you go do you feel
that um constituencies in your home
constituency and and others are taking
up the vaccine as quickly and the
booster as quickly as they should be
i think most people are absolutely
desperate for it most of what i've got
in my inbox at the moment about the
vaccine rollout is from parents of
teenagers
and from
people who are waiting for their booster
job who are wanting to know when they
can get it so i think the vast majority
of the public actually the challenges
how do we get it to them quickly enough
but there are still people who are
reluctant i understand that i spent a
bit of time with a few young people who
had some concerns earlier in the month
some of those concerns particularly for
young women have centred around
fertility i was able with the support of
the the scientists who've been invited
in government to really reassure them
about that and i guess the message that
i would just send to people who are
reluctant to get it is it is safe i've
had it and everybody i know has had it
and it doesn't just protect you it
protects your friends your family your
loved ones and everyone else the only
way we're going to come through this in
the end is through people stepping
forward and getting the vaccine don't
listen to the idiots that are spreading
nonsense in the anti-vaxx movement come
forward get the vaccine
and do your bit for the national effort
okay good to talk to you as always thank
you